[Music]
on this Sunday night cracking down to
prevent the spread of kovat 19 Nova
Scotia's strict measures we are dealing
with a deadly virus and this behavior is
unacceptable what the other provinces
are doing and not doing to control the
corona virus the emergency economic
package we unveiled an eighty two
billion dollar plan politicians get set
to vote but is it enough the shortage of
medical equipment and the dangers facing
healthcare workers start doing things
and from outerspace to personal space
Chris Hadfield guide to self isolation
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us the Canadian government has yet to
declare a national state of emergency
but every single province and territory
have declared some type of health
emergency Nova Scotia is the latest and
the rules are aimed at people within the
province and those from other parts of
this country if you are coming into our
province you'll be stopped at every
entry point questioned and told to self
isolate for those who are not essential
service and want to enter our province
for social purposes please stay home our
Ross Lord is in Nova Scotia Ross premier
Stephen McNeil was very blunt about the
need for people to change their behavior
you could hear it in his voice and he
says that he's still seeing or hearing
of too many people gathering in large
groups at things like beaches and parks
even street hockey games he says they're
blatantly disregarding social distancing
guidelines the new rules limit
gatherings to five people the government
says people can still leave their homes
for things like fresh air or to go out
and pick up groceries but it says
families should identify one person to
make the trip to minimize how many
people are out in public on top of that
effective Monday anyone traveling into
Nova Scotia from another province must
also self isolate exceptions will be
made only for critical supplies or
services and now for a province that was
late to use the word emergency these
restrictions leapfrog others we
therefore have no choice but to call
upon the police and law enforcement
community to enforce self I civilization
and social distancing alright let's talk
about the fines if Nova Scotians don't
abide by these new restrictions lay
those out for us well for individual
violators the fines will be $1,000 for
businesses $7,500
the government wanted to hammer home the
point that there will be additional
repeat fines if violations continue in
some ways
texting the healthcare system here and
limiting the spread of the virus is even
more important in this province because
we have the highest percentage of
seniors in Canada and emergency
departments are already overwhelmed
Robin
all right Ross Lord in nova scotia
tonight nova scotia isn't alone in
virtually shutting down Newfoundland and
Labrador implemented penalties for
people and businesses violating the
social distancing rules but what about
the rest of the country here's Mike
Armstrong now with the different
measures provinces and cities are taking
to combat kovat 19 crews are scrambling
in downtown Montreal the goal is to get
this new kovat 19 testing center up and
running by Monday morning this would
normally be where the city holds major
festivals but these are not normal times
unless you go up the Mount it felt like
a fairly typical Sunday morning in Mount
Royal Park although people say they were
trying to keep their distance from
others I think it's a personal
responsibility now heading out for a
walk or a run is allowed but there's a
problem when too many people head out
with the same idea to the same spot
keeping that suggested 2 meter
distancing is impossible but backing out
Sunday it is now banning social
gatherings in people's homes and any
social gathering outside if they're not
giving that to meters police on
horseback were in the park Sunday
announcing those measures the Premier is
still hoping to avoid having officers
enforce them we want to use police and
the force only in very few exceptions
across Canada streets that would usually
be bustling even on weekends are empty
this is Regina even much of downtown
Toronto feels like a ghost town but
that's not the case everywhere not
everyone's listening to authorities the
mayor of White Rock BC has been
disappointed by some this weekend come
on folks let's make it work for
everybody it's not just about you every
region and every province is having
examples of this the federal Health
Minister can impose fines even have
people jailed under the quarantine act
that is something she says being
considered Ottawa wants all provinces on
the same page for
should we see reluctance on behalf of
the country to pull together that that
would be a time where we would require
additional measures another measure
still on the table is limiting inter
provincial movement something Ottawa
wants to avoid cabinet members say it
could do more harm than help but the
Northwest Territories is now banning
non-essential travel and some provinces
are ordering people to self isolate even
if they're only arriving from another
province in Canada Mike Armstrong Global
News Montreal the number of infected
across Canada jumps by the day there are
now 1,400 confirmed cases in this
country the majority remain in BC and
Ontario both with 424 cases each Quebec
and Alberta are both over 200 cases here
so the rest of the country looks nearly
every region in Canada now reporting
confirmed cases only Nunavut and Yukon
remain off the list
on Tuesday the House of Commons will
reconvene but not all MPs will be there
to vote on the emergency economic
measures the Prime Minister announced
earlier this week our Michael cateura
joins us from Ottawa with what we can
expect Mike well Robin we expect only
about twenty to thirty parliamentarians
to return to the House on Tuesday to
pass what is being described as just the
first government measure to prop up the
economy and Canadians during this crisis
82 billion dollar emergency stimulus
package has been criticized by some
that's too little it will help with wage
subsidies for Canadian workers up to
about 10% now in Denmark the government
is providing wage subsidies of up to 75%
both the finance minister and Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau have cautioned
critics that this is just the first step
they are taking to support Canadians
adding there is more to come there is no
one silver bullet it is going to be many
many different measures brought together
in the most efficient way that will help
us do this now it's unclear when those
other measures will be announced by the
prime minister but he did say they are
already looking at what the next steps
will be as this crisis continues to
evolve now one of the difficulties
though
is how to get all of that money out the
door in the quickest way possible there
is no system to simply print checks for
every adult in this country but in an
interview on the West block Foreign
Affairs Minister Francois Philip Shan
pang said civil servants are working on
getting cash in the hands of Canadians
who are in the most need we need to find
the way the mechanism which is fair
quick and appropriate you know because
we need to have speed and resilience in
that so we need to balance these things
to make sure that what we do is fair but
also it's fast and it's resilient a
Conservative leader Andrew Shearer has
said his party is focused on working
with the government to ensure the
emergency measures help as many people
across the country as possible it's a
signal of a more collaborative tone from
across the political aisle as parties
come together for all Canadians robbing
my clica tour in Ottawa and you can see
the full interview with the Foreign
Affairs Minister later tonight on the
West block with guest host Michael
Couture health care workers are warning
of a critical shortage of life-saving
supplies as Geoff sample reports one
doctor in Toronto is appealing to the
public for donations it's fast become a
must-have accessory
these surgical masks donning faces
across the country but while customers
are stocking up hospitals are running
out every time I see someone on
television wearing a mask whether it's a
surgical mask or an n95 it really makes
my stomach turn this emergency room
doctor says some supplies at his
hospital could run out in less than a
month staff have been told to conserve
and not wear masks unless absolutely
necessary
we should only be routinely using
protective equipment for patients who
have a diagnosis or have you know very
you know sort of concerning symptoms and
so that's where myself and quite a few
my colleagues are feeling uncomfortable
Ontario stockpiled 55 million masks
after SARS but those have since expired
forcing hospitals to compete with the
public to purchase more putting a mask
on someone who's sick makes perfect
sense walking around the city wearing a
mask intermittently there's no evidence
to say that that's going to help you
the masks are required to protect both
patients and healthcare workers in Italy
nearly 10% of frontline hospital staff
have been sidelined with the virus it's
in everybody's best interest to protect
us right now because at baseline we're
running at 110%
starting Monday this hospital in Toronto
is inviting members of the public to
donate and drop off unused unexpired
protective equipment so anything from
surgical masks to protective gloves even
goggles for health officials to use on
the frontlines of the outbreak another
life-saving item in short supply
ventilators these breathing machines for
critically ill patients this toronto
area company is in talks with the
federal government to dramatically ramp
up production of these portable
ventilator units but each one typically
takes more than 20 hours to build
we'll definitely be running into
additional shifts and then once we
understand what the what the demand is
as adding additional people as well the
prime minister says canada is ready for
the anticipated spike in kovat 19 cases
we are confident in our capacity to ramp
up to provide protective equipment for
frontline hospital staff and others who
need it but many of those on the
frontlines don't share that optimism
Jeff Semple Global News Toronto more
than 400 Canadians are now in isolation
for two weeks after arriving back from
Morocco the group landed at Montreal's
Trudeau Airport early this morning the
federal government arranged the pick up
after Morocco cancelled all flights in
and out of the country Canada will send
two additional flights to Morocco this
week for more stranded Canadians the
foreign affairs minister also announced
the feds are working on getting more
repatriation flights to seven other
countries the US has reached a grim
milestone it now has the third highest
number of confirmed Cova 19 cases in the
world
only Italy and China have more over
32,000 Americans have tested positive
for the virus at least 400 have died
more than half of those deaths occurred
in two states New York and Washington
and those states have now been declared
disaster
Arius Jennifer Johnson has more on the
struggles south of the border with the
number of cases of koban 19 rising
rapidly in the u.s. one in four
Americans has been ordered to stay home
and now officials in the hardest hit
areas face another setback a severe
shortage of kovat 19 tests states like
New York and California have enforced a
limit test for only the most ill and
health care workers if the president
doesn't act people will die who could
have lived otherwise early Sunday
evening US President Donald Trump
declared Washington state a disaster
area agreed to send the u.s. naval ships
mercy and comfort to New York and Los
Angeles promised millions more mass
tests and other life-saving supplies and
says he will deploy the National Guard
to the three hardest hit States our goal
is to get relief to Americans as quickly
as possible so that families can get by
and small businesses can keep workers on
the payroll
officials and states with the highest
number of cases worn without additional
supplies from the government they'll run
out by early April nurses and doctors
fearing for their lives this is the
first time in my career I've been a
little scared for my own personal health
and safety businesses fearful to empty
stores in downtown Manhattan are
boarding up to prevent looters they're
not gonna be no one in the city allowed
to walk around so the city is going to
be empty so the people they've taken
avenges to breaking into the stores as
Rand Paul becomes the first u.s. senator
to test positive for the virus Congress
is working on a trillion dollar plus
economic aid package lawmaker is
hammering out the details all weekend we
need to get the money into the economy
now if we do that we think we can
stabilize the economy and you know I
think the president has every
expectation that this is going to look a
lot better four or eight weeks from now
the White House hopes the president can
sign the bill Monday so the government
can help most Americans survive this
crisis at least economically Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington
coming up Croatia is hit with an
earthquake we'll show you the damage and
soldiers clamped down in Italy in a
country already ravaged by the
iris
Croatia is now dealing with two serious
crises Cova 19 and the aftermath of a
powerful earthquake the magnitude 5.4
quake is the biggest to hit the
country's capital in a hundred and forty
years several buildings collapsed and
citizens are being warned to remain
outside because of aftershocks but they
also have to maintain proper distance
from each other because of the virus in
Italy all businesses have been ordered
to close until at least April 3rd
grocery stores and pharmacies will
remain open the new measures are a
desperate attempt to halt the spread of
Cova 19 in the hardest hit country in
Europe there are more than 50 9,000
confirmed cases in the last 24 hours
another 651 people died pushing the
country's death toll above 5,400
Australia is shutting down all
non-essential services as Cova 19 cases
rise rapidly in that country schools
will stay open but parents are allowed
to keep their kids home more than 1300
people have tested positive for Cova 19
in Australia at least seven have died
ghovat 19 is especially difficult for
grieving families unlike many other
events funerals are not something you
can simply postpone but as Amanda jelly
wiki reports funeral homes are adapting
it's probably the hardest thing a family
has to experience saying a final goodbye
while funerals normally unite families
the Cova 19 crisis is forcing them to
stay far apart unfortunately we are all
in the same boat I mean the whole world
is in this situation right now so we're
just trying to figure out some ways to
to help our families live across the
country funeral services are adapting to
the new reality of social distancing
families are encouraged to organize
funerals over the phone or internet in
Montreal most funeral homes are
restricting services to 10 to 20 people
with video streaming options
we are offering some web-based funerals
in two of our homes one in Laval and one
on the south shore so that people can
attend the funeral and there the
families can attend from a distance
they're all practical options people are
adapting to but for grieving families
it's difficult when we experience
morning it's very important to have the
support of friends and family some are
postponing funerals for a few weeks that
isn't possible for some religions like
Islam or Judaism where burials must
happen quickly other perspectives were
meant to be as soon as possible after
somebody dies sitting Shiva is a
fundamental mourning process for the
Jewish community that's when friends and
family visit for a week after a burial
not being able to do that is devastating
and so the people who aren't able to do
that now there's no question in my mind
that it's a loss on top of a loss but
there's equally no question in my mind
that it's the right thing to do hugs so
important to funerals are now also
discouraged instead it's recommended
people touch hands to hearts as a symbol
of love and compassion it's the new
normal in a world that is anything but a
managed on the wiki Global News Montreal
gita' still ahead of former astronauts
down to earth advice on social
distancing news
[Music]
we're spending a lot of time indoors
cooped up with family or in some cases
alone so who better to give advice on
this self isolation than the retired
commander of the International Space
Station start doing things they don't
have to be the things that you always
did before take care of family start a
new project learn to play guitar study
another language read a book write
create Chris Hadfield uploaded advice on
how to cope and self isolation on to
YouTube this weekend it's the subject
he's all too familiar with having spent
a hundred and sixty six days in space
up next the good in people during a time
of crisis
a crisis can bring out the best and the
worst in people and this pandemic is no
exception but we're also seeing generous
acts of kindness and in many ways a
closer sense of community here's Mike
delay with some of the Canadians who are
stepping up we're living in uncharted
territory fear of what could happen has
led to hoarding and panic bringing out
the worst in some which prompted a
family in calgary to do some good they
put together a flyer called neighbors
helping neighbors initially offering to
buy groceries for seniors isolated from
the world because of kovat 19 what it
did is inspire others we have you know
we've got an entire army of volunteers
the offer now is whatever anybody needs
they'll be there and what Stephen Webb
has figured out it was never about
groceries and it's starting to get a
real good feel of you know what nobody's
alone here anything that happens we're
gonna go through as a group as a
community no one's gonna get through
this alone it didn't cost them anything
yet it gave so much the cost of giving
was more acute for Ryan Cooper after
Saint Patrick's Day was canceled leaving
the st. James gate Irish pub with a
fridge full of produce and a choice yeah
it's all been given away this is all the
produce and all the stuff that was
perishable kovat 19 may have shut his
doors but it created an opportunity to
share with families fearful of going out
so it seems silly for it to go to waste
we wanted to do something with it so we
try to do that
Nash la Mer Hebb had two goals when she
moved to small shelving unit under the
sidewalk in front of her Ajax Ontario
house helped a few people and teach her
kids a valuable life lesson I just want
them to learn how to be compassionate to
others how to care for other humans I
just I'm all for love and caring for
other people
she's restocked twice already her 20
flower pots are down to one but
considering the mad rush by some to buy
toilet paper almost all the roles she
put out are still there two families and
a pub manager living nowhere near each
other yet connected in a time of
isolation by values we so desperately
need micro like global news Toronto and
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Robin Gill we'll keep bringing you
the latest on Cove at 19 but we leave
you tonight with an old song that adds a
new twist
[Music]
Neil Diamond reworked sweet Caroline for
social media changing the lyrics to
promote the importance of hand-washing
while fighting the virus thank you for
watching have a great night
[Music]
Sweet Caroline
[Music]